Transcription: Ninon Rauh
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Je suis une merde.
(rires)
Voilà , comme ça, c'est dit.
J’ai fondé un média
qui s’appelle le Crayon.
Je m'appelle Antonin Marin.
On cumule des dizaines
de millions de vues par mois,
on a des centaines de milliers d’abonnés,
et pourtant, je suis une merde.
Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Avec le Crayon,
on a compris, j’ai compris,
en tant que rédacteur en chef,
un problème :
celui des bulles idéologiques.
Pour qui n’est pas familier
avec ce problème-là,
rapidement, les bulles idéologiques,
c’est quand vous likez des vidéos de chats
sur les réseaux sociaux,
Facebook, Instagram vous recommanderont
des vidéos de chats, encore et encore.
Quand c’est des vidéos
de chats, de chiens,
ce que vous aimez comme animaux,
pas de problème.
En revanche, ça devient problématique
quand on parle d'idées politiques.
Et du coup, voyons ce problème-là.
Au Crayon, on fait des formats
de débats, d’interviews
pour tenter de résoudre ce problème.
Mais je pense qu’il y a un problème
plus fondamental, à la racine, à trouver.
Il se trouve dans les personnes.
Pour ça, j’ai élaboré une théorie,
que je vous présente ce soir,
pour la première fois,
donc j’aimerais que vous applaudissiez.
(applaudissements)
C’est « The Shit Theory ».
Cette théorie, c’est « The Shit Theory ».
Je l’ai mis en anglais, parce que
ça a toujours plus de gueule en anglais,
mais en français :
« Théorie de la merde ».
Grosso modo, c’est se considérer
chacun comme une merde,
pour que le monde puisse
avancer de la meilleure des façons.
Voilà grosso modo
la « Théorie de la merde ».
Donc, comme je disais,
on est arrivé à un constat,
celui des bulles idéologiques.
Et je voulais, dans un premier temps,
vous poser une question.
Imaginons qu’on vous propose un dîner.
Et vous avez le choix entre
soit dîner avec votre famille,
des amis, des gens
vraiment que vous appréciez,
soit dîner avec des inconnus
dont vous ne connaissez ni les us
ni les coutumes, rien du tout.
Qu’est-ce que vous allez choisir ?
La plupart des gens diront :
« Ma famille, mes amis.
Je veux passer un bon moment.
Pourquoi m’embêter
à aller dîner ailleurs,
chez des gens que je ne connais pas
Pourquoi ? »
Et la question c’est  « Oui, pourquoi ? »
Fondamentalement, tout le monde,
comme je disais, va choisir cette option.
Mais si tout le monde
choisissait vraiment cette option-là,
eh bien, l’espèce humaine
n’existerait plus.
Je vous rassure, si vous avez choisi
cette option, c’est humain,
et c’est tout à fait normal.
Maintenant, la question,
c’est de se dire pourquoi et comment
on peut essayer de faire en sorte
d’aller voir des inconnus,
d’aller voir ce qui se passe ailleurs.
Ailleurs que dans notre propre bulle,
justement.
Et donc, pour revenir à cette histoire
de dîner chez des inconnus, ou pas,
fondamentalement, ça se comprend.
Au néolithique, les êtres humains
n’avaient pas envie
d’aller dans une autre tribu,
au risque de se faire tuer.
Aujourd’hui, au pire des cas,
vous risquez quoi ?
Peut-être de passer une mauvaise soirée,
d’être mal reçu.
Sauf si votre voisin est Jeffrey Dahmer.
Mais j’espère pas !
(rires)
Dans tous les cas,
vous ne risquez pas grand-chose
à aller dîner avec des inconnus.
Pourtant, ça ne se passe pas.
Et pourtant, très peu de gens décident
d’aller voir des inconnus.
Et on peut trouver une raison à ça.
Comme je le disais,
fondamentalement dans notre esprit
et dans notre cerveau,
qui est fondamentalement faible d’esprit.
Notre cerveau veut des récompenses
tout le temps, il veut être content,
et pas du tout des choses désagréables.
On peut comparer les bulles idéologiques,
le fait de toujours être avec des gens
qu’on aime, des idées qu’on apprécie,
au gras qu’on peut retrouver
dans les fastfoods.
Les fastfoods l’ont bien compris :
le gras, le cerveau aime bien ça,
c’est facile à manger, on l’apprécie.
En revanche, on ne peut pas
se nourrir que de gras,
sinon on connaît les conséquences.
C'est pareil pour les bulles idéologiques.
On ne peut pas se nourrir que d’entre soi,
sinon ça devient
la catastrophe dans la société.
Pour résumer :
les bulles sont aux réseaux sociaux
ce que le gras est au fastfood.
Alors ? Quel est le danger, justement ?
Le danger, c’est que ces bulles,
chacun dans sa bulle, sa propre bulle
ne se rencontre pas, ne se parle pas.
Et nous, c’est ce qu’on a vu aussi,
au Crayon,
parce qu’on est très axé
politique, société, et on le voit,
notamment avec les réseaux sociaux,
les gens ne veulent plus se parler.
Les gens se convainquent
qu’ils ont raison,
dans leur propre coin, entre eux,
élaborant leurs propres théories,
validant leurs propres thèses
et n’acceptant pas
qu’on aille contre ces thèses.
Alors pour essayer de faire en sorte
que ces bulles ne s’éloignent pas
les unes des autres,
il faut les confronter,
créer une compétition.
Au Crayon, on a créé un ring,
une compétition entre deux personnes
représentantes de ces bulles,
venant discuter.
Ce qui permet à ces bulles
non pas chacune de s’éclater,
mais au contraire,
de se briser un peu, de se rencontrer.
Comme dit, le gras est sain,
pour la santé, le cerveau,
on a besoin de notre famille, nos amis,
les bulles sont saines,
on ne va pas les éclater
mais simplement les briser,
de se faire rencontrer les gens
d’une bulle à l’autre.
On le voit à la compétition :
au Crayon, on le fait via des débats,
mais le voit aussi dans l’Histoire.
Un exemple,
lors de la Révolution française.
Nicolas de Condorcet.
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissiez
déjà ce nom, mais Condorcet
va mener une bataille acharnée
pour que l’école privée
continue à exister en France,
car les révolutionnaires voulaient
abolir l’école privée et qu’il n’existe
que des écoles publiques.
La bulle publique, la bulle privée.
Et Nicolas de Condorcet considérait
qu’il fallait justement
que le privé continue d’exister
pour générer cette compétition
avec l’école publique.
Car sans compétition,
si les deux bulles ne se croisaient plus,
c’était la fin de l’une comme de l’autre.
Donc la compétition est nécessaire
et ça, on peut le retrouver
de manière plus globale avec des États.
Par exemple
avec les États-Unis et l’U.R.S.S.,
pendant la guerre froide,
avec la compétition
pour aller sur la Lune.
Donc fondamentalement,
ces bulles ont besoin de se retrouver.
Mais le réel danger, comme je le disais,
c’est que ces bulles s’éloignent.
Et ces bulles peuvent s’éloigner,
pas à cause des réseaux sociaux -
ils ne sont qu’un amplificateur,
ils ne créent pas
le phénomène en lui-même.
Pourquoi les bulles s’éloignent ?
Parce que les gens,
à l’intérieur de ces bulles,
certaines personnes,
veulent que certaines bulles
n’existent plus
ou que la bulle s’éloigne
des autres bulles.
Certaines personnes dans certaines bulles
sont à l’aise dans leur confort
et dans celui-ci, ils veulent
repousser le plus loin possible
les autres bulles, de peur que
d’autres idées viennent dans leur bulle.
Je dis des idées,
ça peut être autre chose.
Inversement, des personnes
dans certaines bulles sont si confiantes
que leur bulle est la meilleure,
qu’ils veulent éclater
absolument toutes les autres bulles.
Donc le problème réside dans les personnes
et c’est pour ça que j’ai établi
cette magnifique théorie.
Donc j’y reviens : la théorie de la merde.
Je n’ai rien inventé.
Je dis que j’ai inventé des trucs,
j’ai rien inventé, c’est juste un appel
tout simple à l’humilité.
Quand je dis « la merde »,
ce n’est pas dire qu’on est nul,
qu’on fait des choses pas bien.
Pas du tout.
C’est juste essayer de se considérer
au niveau zéro de l’humanité.
Se dire que la personne en face de moi,
celle avec qui je parle,
celle que je rencontre,
celle que j’écoute,
elle est un être humain, comme moi.
C’est essayer d’enlever la valeur perçue
pour ne se concentrer
que sur la valeur réelle.
La valeur perçue, on peut dire
que c’est le statut social, l’éducation,
tout ce qui englobe une personne,
quand on la voit, tous les artifices.
La théorie de la merde, ça dit :
« Enlevons les artifices, regardons juste
la personne qu’on a dans les yeux. »
Et on lui dit :
« Je suis humain. Tu es humain.
Viens, on parle, on discute, on se pose,
on se fait un petit dîner tranquille,
pas de soucis.
Il n’y a pas de soucis,
justement parce qu’on est humain.
Et donc le problème de cette théorie,
et quand j’ai dit
« je suis une merde » vous vous êtes dit
« Houla ! Ce gars n’est pas net.
Il est un peu chelou.
J’ai pas envie de fréquenter un gars
qui n’a pas confiance en lui.
C’est peu bizarre. »
Au contraire, l’idée, c’est de se dire
« Enlevons notre ego.
Essayons de nous détacher
le plus possible de cet ego
et de juste s’intéresser à l’humain. »
Et ce n’est pas facile. Pas du tout.
Mais pour ça, j’ai quelques pistes
qui peuvent nous aider à essayer justement
d’appliquer cette théorie
et petit à petit de rencontrer
des personnes qui sont
dans d’autres bulles que les nôtres.
Et une des pistes fondamentales,
c’est le dialogue.
La discussion. Parler.
Dans certaines religions,
on considère que le dialogue,
la parole toute simple,
c'est là où se transmet la Parole de Dieu.
On est croyant, on ne l’est pas,
on peut dire qu’en tant qu’être humain,
c’est peut-être là où se trouve la vérité
des choses justes, dont on n’a pas idée.
Essayer de se dire que la vérité
ou ce qui nous semble parfois vrai,
ou des choses qui nous semblent
parfois évidentes
parce qu’on les a intériorisées,
on les pense, on est sûr de ça,
il suffit juste de les dire parfois,
d’en parler avec quelqu’un
pour se rendre compte à quel point
notre raisonnement ne tient pas du tout.
Et donc ça permet le dialogue,
de se rendre compte de ses propres failles
et donc de se destituer petit à petit
de toutes les valeurs superflues
qui nous englobent.
Pour vous donner un exemple personnel :
j’ai fondé le Crayon après avoir fait
des études de mathématiques.
J’ai fait une prépa, sans doute
comme certains d’entre vous qui êtes ici.
Je voulais étudier les maths, persuadé
que les maths étaient la science ultime,
et que j’étais un génie incroyable
parce que j’étudiais les mathématiques
et que les autres
n’étudiaient pas les maths.
Ok, bon, c’est pas très sérieux.
Oui, c’est pas très sérieux.
Sauf que moi j’étais passionné
de politique, d’actualité,
tout ce que je suis aujourd’hui.
Mais pour moi, c’est juste un plaisir,
pas un travail sérieux.
Et vous voyez, là, c’est de l’ego
que j’avais au fond de moi.
J’étais persuadé que j’étais supérieur
par rapport à cette valeur-là.
Mais on a tous, et je le sais, on a tous
cette petite chose en nous qui nous dit :
« Ah, là-dessus, je suis quand même mieux
que lui, ça me rassure, quand même. »
Ça va, on se rassure comme ça.
Et c’est essayer justement de se dire
« Essayons d’enlever tout ça. »
Car on sera plus à l’aise,
on pourra  faire ce qui nous plaira
et on pourra justement aller parler
avec les autres et éclater ces bulles.
Justement, au Crayon,
on a appris à montrer.
Violine le disait avant,
sur les réseaux sociaux, c’est dur,
il faut montrer ses vidéos,
montrer ce qu’on fait,
tout le temps, être capable
d’accepter toutes les critiques
car tout ce qu’on fait maintenant
est jugé maintenant.
Il faut accepter le fait de se dire
« Oui, en fait, je suis de la merde. »
Si on ne l’accepte pas, la vidéo d’après
sera encore moins vue,
et ce sera encore plus catastrophique.
Donc le travail sur les réseaux sociaux
m’a poussé, et aussi mes associés,
avec qui je travaille tous les jours,
à se remettre continuellement en question
et à ne pas être sûr de :
« Oui bon, ça, là-dessus,
mes compétences, c’est sûr
je suis un boss, y’a pas de soucis,
quoi qu’il arrive,
moi, on ne m’a pas là-dessus. »
Mais en fait, les réseaux sociaux
vous prouvent le contraire.
Aussi sur le rapport à l’humilité.
On n’a jamais besoin tant de l’autre
que quand on est dans un pays étranger.
Je ne sais pas
si vous êtes allés à l’étranger.
Bizarrement, à l’étranger,
on parle avec beaucoup de gens.
Les gens sont intéressants tout de suite.
C’est incroyable !
Mais essayons de réfléchir pourquoi.
Je suis allé récemment en Ukraine
pour faire un reportage de guerre.
Eh oui, les gens, effectivement,
j’avais besoin de leur parler
car j’étais paumé,
car j’étais dans un pays en guerre
et à tout moment,
une bombe explosait à côté de moi.
Ce qui s’est passé deux jours après,
pas à côté de moi, j’étais parti et voilà.
Et vous inquiétez pas.
Mais j’avais ce besoin
d’aller voir l’autre, de comprendre.
Parce que j’étais en situation
de faiblesse, situation où, en fait,
je ne pouvais pas, je n’avais pas
de repères, rien, zéro.
J’étais dépouillé de toutes mes valeurs.
J’avais beau être, je ne sais pas,
président de la république,
sans personne en Ukraine, comme ça,
je n’avais plus de valeur, rien.
Et donc, essayer à chaque fois se dire
que ces expériences personnelles
nous ramènent à des moments
où on n’a plus de valeur
et c’est essayer de tendre aussi
vers ces moments-là.
Il y a un passage de « Choses vues »
de Victor Hugo que j’aime beaucoup.
Je ne sais pas si vous
avez lu cet ouvrage.
Dedans, il y a une scène où
Victor Hugo voit une bourgeoise, une femme
assez riche, qui sort d’un carrosse
et juste à la sortie,
il y a un mendiant, et la bourgeoise
ne lui donne pas d’argent.
Mais c'est même pas ça le plus important.
Le plus important, ce que souligne
Victor Hugo, c’est que
la bourgeoise ne regarde même pas
le mendiant, elle ne le voit pas.
Et Victor Hugo dit que le vrai,
le véritable danger,
ce n’est pas
qu’il y ait un mendiant et une bourgeoise.
Le vrai danger, c’est quand la bourgeoise
n’a plus conscience que le mendiant existe
à partir du moment où la bulle
est tellement éloignée
qu’ils ne se parlent plus.
Donc aujourd’hui, je suis venu
avec toute mon humilité
pour vous dire : « Je suis une merde. »
(applaudissements)